[Music]
the White House build it is a major
address on Democracy but President Joe
Biden's speech was also a shot across
the bow of Republican rival Donald Trump
and his Maga movement and a preview of
the theme of the president's reelection
campaign democracy means rule of the
people not rule of monarchs not rule of
the money not rule of the mighty
regardless of party that means
respecting free and fair
elections accepting the outcome win or
lose it means you can't your country
only when you
[Applause]
win democracy means rejecting and
repudiating political
violence that was a clear reference to
the January 6 2021 Insurrection fomented
by Trump which led to his second
impeachment days ahead of a possible
government shutdown over the demands
from Trump's allies in Congress Biden
accused magga Republicans of destroying
Faith in American institutions Biden
said every generation must protect
democracy and he made clear what threats
this generation faces there's something
dangerous happening in America now
there's an extremist movement that does
not share the basic beliefs in our
democracy the Maga movement Biden made
the address as he announced Federal
funding for the John McCain National
Library named after the late Arizona
senator and Vietnam prisoner of war he
was both Biden's political adversary and
his close friend Biden was introduced by
McCain's Widow once a loyal Republican
wife later a member of Biden's
Democratic Administration John would
have hated if we'd made this occasion
just about him but instead he would have
wanted to make it about what is most
important John's constant Mantra of
service to a cause greater than one's
self-interest it is an honor to serve
the American people McCain died in 2018
in the years since the country's
divisions have only
sharpened it's no accident that Biden
chose Arizona for this speech it is a
key election state that Trump lost in
2020 and that Biden hopes to win again
in 2024 I didn't hear Motion hours
before Biden spoke House Republicans
held a hearing on whether to impeach him
another day of contrasts and clashing
political realities in a deeply divided
America John hendren Al jazer Tempe
Arizona make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaer